[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la laïcité menacée la laïcité
est une marque de culturelle et
démocratique spécifiquement française si
la France s'est constituée de plusieurs
Frances cousu ensemble le vivre ensemble
a pour langage commun depuis la
Révolution française et plus précisément
depuis la loi de 1905 cette fameuse
laïcité depuis de nombreuses adaptations
ont vu le jour et elles sont rendues
nécessaires parce que l'islam politique
entre autres opposition et pour ne pas
parler de l'islamo gauchiste conteste
les institutions et les valeurs
républicaines dernier épisode en date
Gabriel Atal ministre de l'éducation
nationale a décidé d'interdire de nos
écoles le port de laabaya pour les
femmes et le camis pour les hommes cela
rappelle l'affaire du voile les fameux
foulards à crille en 89 et poursivre la
loi de 2004 faisant interdiction de
porter des signes religieux
ostentatoires à l'école nous évoquerons
bien entendu comment s'articule
aujourd'hui la laïcité au sein de
l'éducation et les tensions engendrées
nous ferons aussi une
contextualisation de cette laïcité
malmenée au regard d'une société
française où se développe les
communautarismes les radicalismes les
particularismes identitaires la violence
des jeunes le voauquisme de toutes
sortes de minorités agissantes la montée
des partis extrémistes estce que Laurent
Bouvet nommé l'insécurité culturelle
vous êtes conviés chers invités à un
véritable challenge pour aosculter ce
désenchantement de la laïcité je vais
vous présenter alors Frédéric salabarou
vous êtes avocat ancien secrétaire
général à la présidence de la République
Vincent payon vous êtes ancien ministre
de l'éducation nationale et actuellement
à la Cour des comptes Catherine Kinsler
vous êtes philosophe universitaire et
spécialiste de la laïcité
a Abdel wed vous êtes psychanalyste
professeur des universités et en
visioconférence depuis Jérusalem Michel
gurfinquiel ancien rédacteur en chef de
valeurs actuelles et actuelles
éditorialiste au New York
[Musique]
Sun alors une question d'emblé sur
l'actualité brûlante les meurtres des
enseignants Samuel pati il y a 3 ans et
récemment de Dominique Bernard
interviennent dans un contexte de
djihadisme d'atmosphère selon Gill kpel
qu'en pensez-vous Vincent
payon je pense d'abord
que on vit des drames en France que nous
n'avions pas vécu depuis longtemps dans
l'éducation nationale mais vous vous en
souvenez aussi ailleurs qu'un certain
nombre de nos
concitoyens en
fonction de leur lien soit à l'école qui
est quand on attaque l'école on attaque
une idée de la République la République
mais aussi fonction de leur confession
juifes souvenons-nous des attentats il y
a eu des enfants Français juifs tués
dans une école donc nous vivons un
moment que nous n'avions pas vécu depuis
très longtemps et dont la dimension
tragique on la voit d'ailleurs les jours
où on se parle
ne doit pas être sous-estimée car nous
avions oublié
euh pourquoi c'est quelques décennies
que l'histoire est tragique après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale la guerre a eu
lieu on a reconstruit une unité
nationale d'ailleurs le Goo communisme
la laïcité qui n'était pas contesté mais
aussi beaucoup de principes qu'avaiit en
commun même la gauche et la droite
française ce temps est en train de
passer nous sommes dans ces moments où
quelque chose s'en va quelque chose
naîra mais nous sommes dans l'entredeux
cet entredeux est est violent tragique
parfois répugnant euh les enseignants
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement atteints
tous par ce qui s'est passé et je crois
que deux fois et je crois qu'on doit
faire preuve là d'unité nationale autour
de de ce sujet pas chercher non plus à
l'instrumentaliser trop
euh mais réfléchir comment nous pouvons
effectivement avec la force de l'État
avec l'intelligence de la République et
bien éviter que cela se produise et que
cela gangraine car ça peut gangrainer de
plein de points de vue merci vous
partagez ce cette position Frédéric
salabarou bien sûr je pense que le fait
que
c'est ces actes inqualifiables se
passent à l'école et pas et pas le fruit
du hasard c'est pour des minorités
agissantes l'école c'est le cœur des
valeurs de la République et le fait que
ça soit des professeurs qui sont
attaqués c'est le symbole évidemment la
culture est absolument essentielle et
donc derrière ça il y a une remise en
cause des valeurs de la République et
une remise en cause plus large des
valeurs occidentales et donc ça veut
dire que face à ça il faut à la fois
beaucoup de respect beaucoup de fermeté
parce que ce qui est en jeu est
fondamental ouais catherrine Kinsler
rose oui bien sûr je partage cette cette
analyse il faut je voudrais simplement
rappeler que en 2015 dès 2 15 l'État
islamique avait publié un appel pour
tuer les professeurs particulièrement en
France donc avant l'assassinat de de
Samuel
Patti je pense que l'intégrisme
religieux et le totalitarisme en général
il y a ne déteste rien tant que l'école
et la laïcité parce que la laïcité c'est
le contraire de l'intégrisme il faut
quand même rappeler que le principe de
laïcité ne s'applique pas à tout tout le
monde il y a une dualité du régime
laïque dans la la société civile tout le
monde peut afficher des des des
appartenances dans le cadre du droit
commun ça s'applique là le principe de
laïcité s'applique à un domaine précis
délimité à savoir la puissance publique
et l'école bien entendu avec certaines
nuances hein peut-être on y reviendra et
ne déteste rien tant que l'école
pourquoi parce que l'école est le lieu
en principe de la transmission du savoir
et le savoir et bien il y a pas d'autre
autorité que le savoir pour le savoir il
est immanent à lui-même c'est comme
l'association politique républicaine
elle ne s'autorise que d'elle-même le
savoir c'est la liberté donc c'est
émancipateur voilà oui auiab d'oet
qu'est-ce que vous pensez le savoir
c'est la liberté puis aussi moi je pense
à Anna arent pas de penser aussi sans
liberté et donc je par rapport à Samuel
pati moi je me souviens le lendemain
j'avais un cours d'anthropologie à des
étudiants à parisat à l'époque j'étais à
Paris 7 et j'étais extrêmement affectée
d'abord parce qu'il s'agissait de
l'assassinat d'un collègue d'un être
humain c'est un acte barbare et moi-même
je suis enseignante et moi-même je
travaille sur des sujets très très
houleux et donc je me suis dit comment
aussi aborder les choses avec mes
étudiants on était arrivé arrivé à
durkim et là je me suis dit euh pour
parler de la religion comme fait social
je vais introduire Ibn Khaldoun et là je
vous assure les étudiants étai vraiment
aux anges de découvrir qu'il y avait
aussi des penseurs qui n'avaient rien à
voir avec
ces effectivement ces gens qui sont pour
une pensée fanatique qui sont en train
d'assassiner le savoir donc mais ce qui
je trouve ce qui est intéressant là
c'est que on aborde la question de la
laïcité et tout de suite il y a ce qui
interroge la laïcité c'est-à-dire
l'islam fanatique oui alors on va voir
l'AVE de Michel finquiel sur ce
point le journaliste que vous êtes
observe
quoi j'observe que en
effet jamais peut-être depuis depuis
très longtemps la laïcité n'a été
d'actualité politique en France je
m'explique je ne je suis très méfiant
vis-à-vis des concepts je crois que
c'est un défaut français de confondre
les mots et les choses et plus
exactement de dissimuler les choses
derrière les mots
euh si nous essayons de voir
historiquement sociologiquement ce que
c'est que la démocratie on est tenté de
dire que la démocratie c'est un moyen
d'éviter la guerre civile selon la la
formule célèbre de Kipling il n'y a que
deux manières de gouverner casser les
têtes ou les compter et je crois que la
laïcité historiquement ça servait à
éviter les guerres de religion ou à
mettre fin aux guerres de religion c'est
ça le véritable fondement de
l'attitude laïque dans les sociétés
occidentale et peut-être dans d'autres
sociétés occidentales la laïcité à mon
sens ne n'est pas avec la Révolution
française ni même avec la Révolution
américaine qui lui é qui était
légèrement antérieure elle naît avec les
les traités de
vesphali qui introduisent un concept
révolutionnaire c'est que chaque État de
la chrétienté en réalité a le droit
d'avoir sa propre religion à partir de
ce moment euh on on désacralise l'État
et on on ouvre un espace nouveau qui
rend au sein d'un état d'une façon ou
d'une autre possible une une coexistence
entre plusieurs formes de religion ou en
tout cas dans la Communauté des États
européens qui rend possible cette chose
merci alors Catherine kisler restons
dans
l'actualité
euh la
Constitution en France fait l'objet de
beaucoup de
toilettages c'est pareil pour la laïcité
est-ce que vous pensez que face à ce
qu'on appelle
l'islamogauchisme est-ce que ça provoque
ce que Jean-Pierre legof appelle une
société malade de la peur et qui
engendre une laïcité autocensurée
évidemment ça pose la question de tous
ces professeurs qui s'autocensurent les
sondages sont
effrayants d'abord je voudrais rappeler
que euh cette origine historique qui
vient d'être évoquée moi j'introduiraai
quand même une nuance c'est que la la la
la laïcité à la différence de la
tolérance ne juxtapose pas les religions
les communautés c'est déjà un très grand
progrès mais elle instaure un espace
zéro on compte les Français comptent à
partir de zéro et non pas à partir de 1
c'est un un de mes collègues qui m'a
suggéré cette cette comparaison avec la
numération donc c'est un espace zéro ce
n'est pas un un un évantail
d'appartenance qui pourrait
éventuellement se bon cohabiter mais ça
rend possible les différentes
appartenances et aussi la non
appartenance la non appartenance est une
condition ça je voulais quand même
revenir sur ce point parce que ça a été
vraiment inventé et là c'est à partir de
la Révolution française que ça ça
commence avec le mariage civil et cetera
alors pour euh aborder votre question
oui euh euh les c'est pas une laïcité
autocensurée c'est une autocensure qui
évite euh les les problèmes tout
simplement les les professeurs sont euh
sont confrontés à des intrusions il faut
dire des intrusions de toutes sortes que
au fond une une série de dispositions
réglementaires sur l'école qui ont
introduit les associations beaucoup de
qui ont donné beaucoup de pouvoir aux
parents et finalement les professeurs
sont confrontés à toutes sortes de ce
que j'appelle c'est ce que j'appelle
renvoyer l'école à son
extérieur l'école est constamment
confronté à des demandes sociales comme
si elle devait les satisfaire toutes et
comme si elle devait répondre à ces
demandes social elle doivent s'adapter à
la modernité s'adapter et cetera alors
que le cœur du métier c'est
l'instruction c'est le savoir c'est ce
sont des des dispositifs centraux qui
permettent de faire face aux différentes
évolutions c'est ce que vous avez vu
je pense que les professeurs sont
confrontés à ça et que ils sont des
coupables idéau quand quand ça ne marche
pas Vincent payant vous êtes à la vous
avez été ministre et vous êtes
enseignant vous avez également fait de
l'enseignement les profs ont peur comme
dit auin vous je pense que c'était
également le cas à votre époque pour
faire un peu avancer le le sujet je
voudrais lancer quelques idées comme ça
d'abord il faut pas avoir une fausse
conception parle de savoir celle des
ignorants sur la laïcité sachez mon cher
Émile que jusqu'en 1923 à l'époque des
barbu il y a les devoirs envers Dieu
dans les instructions officielles de la
France et on n' pas arracher les
crucifis des écoles on s'est accommodé
ceux qui ont fait la grande loi libérale
de 1905 n'était pas antireligieux loin
de là ce n'était pas des laïcars comme
on nous a présenté si déjà on évitait
ces sotises on verrait que la laïcité
qui doit reposer sur l'assentiment
intérieur pourrait séduire plus à mon
avis de jeunes gens deuxièmement vous
avez pas parler de l'islam et vous
immédiatement l'islamogauchisme ça c'est
les listes macartistes que j'ai vu comme
directeur de recherche CNS circuler en
France à nouveau c'est pas très joli la
dénonciation et mon histoire personnelle
fait que je neaime pas mais moi j'ai été
ministre vous l'avez rappelé vous avez
eu cette gentillesse mais j'ai été
confronté au problème de l'islam radical
et politique mais aussi lorsque j'ai
voulu introduire comme tous les grands
pays occidentaux parce que nous c'est un
pays où il y a pas de femme ingénieur
pas de femm scientifiques une lutte
contre les stéréotpes type de genre là
on est sur les contenus de savoir pour
faire des mathématiques c'est pas
l'islam j'en avais un peu radical que
j'avais en face de moi c'est aussi des
catholiques exacerbés français d'une
violence sans limite et qui ont fait
reculer le gouvernement car je vous
rappelle il n'est pas revenu là-dessus
que le dispositif égalité fille garçon a
été supprimé en 2015 après mon départ
ils n'ont pas tenu ils n'ont pas tenu
sur quelque chose qui concernait les
savoirs et j'entends maintenant
président de la République ministre
Premier ministre toutes les mêmes qu'il
l'ont supprimé dira il y a un problème
d'égalité fille garçon dans l'école
française donc il faut complexifier
notre point de vue si on ne veut pas
commettre des erreurs considérables et
mon plus grand souci lorsque j'ai à la
fois relancé l'enseignement moral et
civique que j'avais appelé moral laïque
mais j'ai vu que personne savait ce que
ça voulait dire et en même temps
afficher la charte de la laïité la
première dans tous les établissements de
France c'est celle qui reste c'est que
ce qui me souciait le plus c'est que
beaucoup de Français de petits Français
qui n'avaient pas la même histoire que
mienne voyez maintenant la République et
la laïcité comme quelque chose qui était
leur adversaire par l'émancipation mais
quand on peut parler de ça une une une
oppression possible une domination
possible une question comm je finis
juste là-dessus comme la laïcité
intérieur tel que je la vois c'est être
capable de douter aussi de ses propres
assurances c'est cartésien dans le fond
la laïcité je me suis interrogé sur
est-ce qu'on fait bien est-ce qu'il faut
pas faire autrement parce qu'il faut les
faire venir ir à cette laïcité nous
voyons bien qu'aujourd'hui moi je pense
comme vous d'ailleurs je vous ai lu
qu'il y a deux dangers pour la laïcité
le danger je dirais de de toutes les
intolérances des extrémismes des
fanatismes mais le danger d'un certain
nombre de gens qui croientê des laïques
mais qui comme mon maître Ferdinan buon
qui a quand même fait l'établissement de
la République en France sont des
nouveaux inquisiteurs cré une nouvelle
orthodoxie de nouveaux dogmes et ne sont
pas dans cette pensée interrogative et
inclusive une précision pas on va pas
rester longtemps là-dessus mais une
précision pourquoi l'enseignement des
faits religieux n'a pas
fonctionné vous étiez ministre est-ce
que on pouvait pas avant déjà ça na fond
c'est une très belle idée je dois vous
dire mais qui dans notre pays alors
d'abord n'a pas été compris d'un certain
nombre de gens qui pensent être laïque
en combattant le le fait religieux
ensuite nous avons une énorme un énorme
pardon problème de formation des
enseignants sur ce sujet qui ne s'en
sont pas saisis vous savez si vous
prenez l'histoire de l'école
républicaine très souvent et c'est le
cas d'ailleurs de la morale laïque elle
a été voulue par certains on pourra en
faire l'histoire pourquoi parce que Laé
est plus complexe mais ça n'a pas marché
ça non plus on n pas su l'enseigner ce
qui est facile à enseigner c'est
l'instruction civique les lois les
droits les devoirs et cetera ça chaque
fois ça send pe un marxiste ou un
libéral peut enseigner l'économie on on
aurait pu enseigner les faits religieux
sans appartenance religieuse ch que vous
économie vous savez qu'il y a d'énormes
polémique sur l'enseignement justement
des sciences économiques en mais
l'enseignement du fait religieux c'est
une vraie difficulté d'enseignement
alors dans l'actualité Frédéric
salabarou monsieur hatal ministre de
l'éducation nationale a interdit laaba
et le camis mais est-ce que ça n'allait
pas de soi si on se réfère à la loi de
2004 à laquelle vous étiez associé à
l'époque de la présidence Chirac oui
bien sûr c'est le c'est c'est
l'application de la loi de 2004 mais je
voudrais revenir sur parce que le
problème c'est qu'on plonge aujourd'hui
laïcité interdit et interdit contre
l'islam c'est pas ça du tout la laïcité
alors ça préexiste sans doute à la
révolution mais c'est une loi de liberté
c'est la liberté de croire ou de ne pas
croire sans contrainte et sans et sans
pression et la laïcité si le problème
c'est qu'elle est pas comprise elle est
pas enseignée on n'est pas formé à la
laïcité la laïcité est contre personne
euh prenons des exemples euh la
l'interdiction du du voile à l'école on
parle du voile à l'école mais c'est
également l'interdiction
desquipa pour les Juifs le voile n'est
pas une obligation religieuse la kipa
est une est une obligation religieuse
donc ça concerne toutes les religions si
on prend le catholicisme qui reste la la
religion majoritaire en France quand on
interdit euh les crèches dans les
mairies ou quand on interdit par exemple
dans le mortbian la statue de Jean-Paul
II qui est surmontée d'une croix c'est
le même principe aucune des religions ne
se retrouve surtout dans la laïité pay a
des traditions Fréd salabarou mais la
laïcité c'est le fait de préserver
l'espace public ça n'est pas contre
l'islam c'est pas une ce n'est pas des
des principes de contrainte des
principes qui permettent à chacun de
vivre dans la liberté et donc pour
revenir à la BAA puisque mais je crois
que c'est important de de partir de ça
il faut d'abord expliquer ce qu'est la
laïcité et c'est pas n'importe quel
principe l'article 1er de notre
Constitution dit la France est une
République indivisible laïque
démocratique et sociale le laïque vient
en 2èe donc c'est un principe
fondamental et pour revenir à la BAA oui
quand on regarde l'exposé des motifs de
la loi de 2004 dit tous les signes ou
tenus
ostensibles sont interdits c'est-à-dire
ceux qui se font font reconnaître la
personne qui les porte immédiatement en
fonction de sa religion donc c'est le
cas de la BA vous parlez neutralité
neutralité mais quand on se promène en
France dans les
villages dans les grandes villes c'est
ponctué d'églises partout on en trouve
partout les vacances scolaires ont lieu
à bon donc est-ce que on doit faire F
des traditions religieuses d'un pay
laïité ce n pas contre les religions au
contraire c'est un cadre qui permet à
chacune des religions de de d'ailleurs
de ceux qui croient ou qui ne croient
pas de s'exprimer c'est certainement pas
aujourd'hui on va pas être à rebours des
choses un instrument pour faire
privilégier la tradition chrétienne de
la France par rapport à d'autres
traditions d'autres religions bien au
contraire et c'est un cadre qui est
profondément moderne sauf qu'aujourd'hui
il est ni expliqué ni
défendu abdalwa là-dessus alors moi je
je je j'écoute et c'est vrai que c'est
un débat houleux et passionnant en même
temps enfin croyance ça m'a fait penser
à cette superbe phrase de André Mickel
que j'aime beaucoup croire ou rêver donc
effectivement la laïcité n'est pas ne
convoque pas euh l'obligation d'une
croyance chrétienne ou et cetera c'est
la liberté offerte à chacun de croire ou
de ne pas croire sans vraiment que le ne
pas croire
entraîne des répressions comme dans
certains pays ou décapitations ou autres
alors par rapport à l' la cette cette
histoire de habaya donc moi je la
prononce à l'arabe la habaya moi il y a
deux questions qui qui qui me viennent
je m'interroge d'abord sur la régression
du féminisme en France je me dis comment
se fait-il moi quand je suis venu
étudiant en France la habaya n'existait
pas le voile n'existait pas le burkini
n'existait pas et la question religieuse
n'existait pas ce qui faisait l'Union ou
la relation entre les étudiants là je
parle de mon passé d'étudiante c'était
être passionné par le cinéma par la
psychanalyse par la littérature
c'est-à-dire des choses qui faisaient
lien et non pas qui séparit donc d'abord
la régression du féminisme en France et
deuxièmement la habaya donc moi j'ai
écrit beaucoup sur ça d'abord n'existe
pas dans le Coran et donc quand Aure dit
c'est un fait civilisationnel mais
absolument pas et donc euh là je je je
dirais en tant que
psychanalyste parce que ça concerne
quand même les adolescentes donc aussi
euh quelle est cette attitude
adolescente en lien avec le corps
sachant que le corps est lié au
pulsionnel à la sexualité à la question
de l'ibidina la question de la honte de
montrer mon corps et cetera donc c'est
une façon qui est en en même temps qui
consiste à cacher et à montrer donc lié
aussi à certaines quelque chose qui est
en train aussi de de de de de venir
au-devant de la scène sans qu'on sache
ce que c'est c'est la question de
l'identité religieuse et c'est là où il
y a problème ça veut dire quoi une
identité religieuse sachant que
l'identité c'est un processus c'est une
fabrique elle est en marche donc la
question de la habaya elle englobe une
complexité qui n'est pas réduite à
quelque chose qu'on appelle fait
civilisationnel parce qu'il n'est pas
civilisationnel merci alors moi je
voudrais qu'on sorte un peu de la
théorie et qu'on rentre dans ce qui
existe pardonnez-moi si la communauté
musulmane de France s'inscrit pour
l'essentiel dans le vivre ensemble on
observe parmi la jeunesse qui en est
issue à la fois une aine antirrançaise
et de l'antisémitisme Catherine
Kinsler écoutez je je quand même réagir
à ce qui est ce que je viens d'entendre
qui est très riche euh mais ce n'est pas
sans rapport avec votre question il me
semble que ce qui est ciblé c'est ce
sont des tests à partir de
d'incompréhension ou d'incompréhension
entretenu la laïcité comme euh
interdiction et cetera non et moi je
voudrais rappeler ce que j'ai ce que
j'appelle la respiration laïque c'est
dire que nous avons deux domaines le
domaine de la société civile où tout le
monde peut afficher ses ses appartenance
et puis le domaine de la de l'autorité
publique et de l'école où il faut les
suspendre c'est une respiration l'école
offre une double
vieou ça on est bien d'accord mais ce
qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est cette
double vie justement qui est récusée par
l'intégrisme parce que l'intégrisme il
veut que la vie soit uniforme qu'elle
soit la même partout moi j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai coécrit avec ellisabeth Badinter
Alain finkelcot Régis de BR ellisabeth
de Fontenet en 1989 le fameux appel prof
ne capitulons pas c'était une
déclaration
d'anti-intégrisme cette déclaration là
puisque on disait voilà si vous
permettez l'intrusion de tous les
affichage au fond des identités qui on
dirait aujourd'hui qui se signalent par
des tags au fond qui sont comme des on
on construit son identité comme une
pizza avec des ingrédients disponibles
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on construit
une identité on se cherche on doute et
bien si vous autorisez cela vous donnez
raison à tous ceux qui disent par
exemple aux jeunes aux jeunes filles
voilées tu dois te voiler partout tout
le temps partout tout le temps voilà
c'est comme ça que je verrai les choses
et donc si nous avons aujourd'hui cette
vague de d'intégrisme et bien c'est
précisément cette euh ce ce cette
tendance à vouloir installer la même loi
partout il n'y a pour moi qu'une parole
qu'une tendance et tous ceux qui s'y
opposent doivent être éliminés al leors
éliminer politiquement euh
idéologiquement physiquement nous le
voyons oui voilà merci Michel
gurfinquiel comment vous voyez puisque
vous voyagez beaucoup cette montée de
l'antisémitisme et de l'antif France
dans les banlieux
françaises je me bornerais à dire que
c'est c'est un fait sociologique c'est
un fait sociologique on peut l'expliquer
de mil une
manière il y a les les idées abstraites
et il y a à
côté la la
en tant que bouillon de culture en tant
que
condensation
de de tout de tous les mythes de tout de
toutes les pulsions qui ont pu exister
dans l'histoire humaine le bouillon de
culture ne s'éteint jamais est-ce que
les les idées que je qualifie
d'abstraite parce qu'elles sont
raisonnées ont le moyen de discipliner
le bouillon de culture c'est le point
c'est le point essentiel est-ce que nous
n'avions pas une une certaine pratique
qui nous permettait de le faire
jusqu'à peut-être une génération de nous
et est-ce que nous avons pas perdu cette
pratique cette pratique suppose bien
entendu de l'autorité elle suppose de la
verticalité elle suppose que de la
souveraineté elle suppose que l'État
dise à un moment ou un autre et bien
voilà comment je veux que les chose
existe et que l'État également travaille
à constituer un consensus autour de sa
décision oui mais l'autorité politique
est remise en question n'est-ce pas
Vincent payon c'est toutes les autorités
qui sont remises en question pour aller
un peu dans le sens de ce que vous
disiez je crois bon il y a un nouveau
féminisme ne négligez pas en même temps
qui est beaucoup plus radical que celui
qu' a connu ma génération et peut-être
la vôtre donc le féminisme n'a pas
disparu on voit même que beaucoup s'en
inquiètent dans les universités et
ailles disparu excusez-moi mais par
rapport par exemple il y a quelques
années le burkini leini c'était des des
choses qui n'existaient pas mais
n'existeit pas dans le regard aussi de
ceux qui commentent quand vous êtes en
responsabilité d'une nation et que vous
devez faire vivre tout le monde ensemble
à la dans cette rentrée scolaire il
manque plusieurs milliers de professeurs
devant les élèves plusieurs milliers
d'élèves n'ont pas trouvé d'inscription
on est attaché au savoir il faut quand
même des professeurs monsieur Atal a
interdit et très bien la baaya je l'ai
rencontré et il l'a rendu publique
combien de cas sur 12 millions d'élèves
200 si l'on regarde dans les journaux le
traitement de ces 200 cas qu' fallait
peut-être traité je n'ai pas de sujet
là-dessus par rapport au traitement de
l'absence de professeurs dans nos lycées
d'inscription pour nos élèves c'est
scandaleux et quand on veut gérer un
pays au nom de l'intérêt général et
d'une certaine idée de la France liée à
l'instruction premier mot de nos
Instructions Officielles l'école en
instruisant éduque à la liberté on se
préoccupe autant de mettre des
professeurs bien formés devant les
élèves que la longueur de débat
stigmatiser certains et traiter que de
ces problèmes donc il faut les traiter
avec fermeté mais il faut quand même
mesurer qu'elle abaissement intellectuel
et d'action publique c'est de ne pas se
poser les grandes questions concernant
la formation de nos professeurs leur
recrutement leur présence dans les
établissements leurs remplacement quand
ils ne sont pas là et cetera et cetera
et sans doute aussi les disciplines que
l'on enseigne donc vous êtes d'accord
quand vous êtes d'accord quand Gabriel
hatal dit que les manquements aux
valeurs républicaines excluent les
élèves qui s'en qui s'en inspirent et
qui sont porteurs de ce les élèves et et
et et les adultes et les hommes
politiques qui se trouvent dans des
situations auss très curieuses moi j'ai
connu un président de la République qui
considérait que l'imam le Rabin et
cetera valait mieux que le professeur
pour enseigner les donc il faut aussi
mesurer que c'est pas à l'école de
résoudre tous les problèmes les
problèmes sont aussi dans la société la
violence est dans la société
l'abaissement intellectuel est dans la
société et il ne faut pas chercher
quelques bouc émissairire il faut de
l'autorité il faut rappeler ces
choses-là mais il faut les
contextualiser alors la dernière chose
que je voudrais dire c'est pour notre
génération il y a et et et moi je l'ai
vécu comme professeur à Nanterre dans
dans ce lycée très difficile mais
c'était il y a déjà 30 ans qui a c'est
récemment on parler d'ailleurs de cette
ép c'est que les grands récits moi je
une famille
communiste famille communiste beaucoup
de Juifs intellectuel étit communist
j'aiétaé levé par des gens comme ça le
socialisme a fait rêver des gens le
goulisme a tenu des gens mais il faut
regarder les choses en face ces grands
récits se sont effondrés peut-être même
la promesse républicaine n'a pas été
totalement tenue pour certains peut-être
une histoire se redécouvre et nous avons
tout ça à gérer et une jeunesse sur
notre territoire à gérer c'est un peu
plus complexe que uniquement des bouts
de tissu 200 personnes et la
stigmatisation d'une population c'est
toute notre histoire nationale qu'il
faut réécrire ensemble en étant capable
de trouver une place à chacun Michel
gurfinquel voulait intervenir oui je par
rapport à ce que Vincent payon vient de
dire sur son successeur Gabriel Atal euh
Gabriel Atal de toute évidence a procédé
à son interdiction de la BAA parce qu'il
savait au préalable il y a eu des
sondages dans ce sens qui datent du mois
de juin SAU ferreur que qu'il y avait
une une majorité écrasante écrasante en
France pour l'interdiction de ce ce
signe ostensible et ostentatoire non
seulement d'une religion mais d'un
fondamentaliste ou d'un extrémisme
religieux quand
euh le ministre de l'éducation nationale
a effectivement pris sa décision qui
d'ailleurs ne se réduit à l'application
de la loi telle qu'elle existe nous
avons à nouveau pu mesurer le soutien
que que celle-ci euh rencontrait dans
l'opinion puisque disons que le soutien
est allé de je je cite de mémoire mais
c'est très facile à vérifier de 90
% à droite jusqu'à 79 % chez les
électeurs socialistes on VO on le
prendra après frééric salab je crois que
la la question que vous posez et je
prends un tout petit peu de temps pour
répondre est fondamental moi je suis pas
convaincu mais il faut n'en débattons
pas qu'il ait une généralisation du
sentiment antifance mais à supposer euh
il y a deux terrains sur lequel on doit
agir d'abord la défense du modèle
français euh on prend 2 secondes avec un
peu de recul et c'est valable aussi pour
l'quisme mais dans quel pays euh quand
un enfant nî il est pris en charge par
l'État il y a des aides immédiatement on
on est on peut accoucher gratuitement
dans un hôpital l'éducation est gratuite
quand il y a des accidents de la vie la
société là la vieillesse n'est plus
synonyme de misère qu'on soit riche ou
pauvre quand on a un cancer on est
soigné avec une grande qualité mais il
faut d'abord que ça soit dit
c'est-à-dire ce pays avant de lui
cracher dessus il faut commencer d'abord
par lui dire merci ça c'est le premier
point et ça ça n'est pas dans la parole
politique la deuxième chose c'est
l'autorité faut faire un peu d'histoire
prenons la laïcité mais en 1905 jusqu'en
1909 le PAP
pidis prend une bulle pour considérer
que la loi est
inacceptable des
cardinaux disent il ne faut pas
appliquer la loi et les personnes qui
l'appliqueront leurs enfants ne pourront
pas faire la première communion dans un
pays qui a 90 % de catholique et on
donnera pas les sacrements qu'est-ce que
fait l'état l'état envoie des cardinaux
des évêques des centaines de prêtres en
application de l'article 31 de la loi
1905 devant le tribunal correctionnel et
ils sont condamnés c'est aussi ça
l'autorité et donc c'est pas la même
période mais l'autorité que ça soit dans
la spire de la société ou à l'école doit
s'imposer il y a des règles on peut
aujourd'hui poursuivre c'est l'article
433 3 du Code pénal tout ce qui est
menace de vis-à-vis de personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique donc
ce que ce qui doit être fait c'est
d'abord la défense de notre modèle et
l'autorité alors le professeur ne peut
pas tout faire mais c'est à l'État
d'aider le professeur c'est le rapport
entre la justice la police et le
autorité qui doit rentrer de manière
républicaine aussi dans l'école mais les
défis qu'on a sont pas tellement plus
lourds à assumer que ceux de de 1909
quand tu as 90 % d'un pays qui est
catholique et un pape qui dit
n'appliquez pas la loi et que les grands
prêts là le 10 en cher c'est compliqué
et pourtant la République a fait face
donc maintenant vous disiez c'est une
question d'autorité de l'État c'est
fondamentalement une question d'autorité
de l'État mais dans ce caslà de plus
noble oui Catherine kinler oui je mercie
d'avoir rappelé que au fond c'est un
acte unilatéral de la puissance publique
qui s'impose et nous avons besoin de cet
acte de renouveler cet acte quel que
soit les les les devant les obstacles
alors je voulais simplement dire que il
faut instruire il faut recruter les
professeurs sur un haut niveau mais
encore faut-il leur donner les
conditions pour travailler la sérénité
et ces obstacles ces tests auxquels ils
font face et auxquels ils essayent de
répondre les uns par évitement les
autres parce que bon en ayant suivi ce
fameux pas de vague comment le leur
reprocher quand ils sont constamment en
but à des
critiques et plus que cela même c'est
une litotte donc il faut que cette
autorité s'impose leur donner alors donc
moi je ne suis pas choqué par ce
traitement de la BA parce que ce sont
les obstacles qu'il faut traiter d'abord
il faut les lever ces obstacles et vous
avez parfaitement raison de nous
rappeler comment fonctionne cette cette
autorité alors je voulais simplement
dire au fond j'ai dit tout à l'heure
l'école doit offrir une double vie à
chaque élève moi je suis fille
d'immigré ma tante qui était donc
d'origine italienne elle était très
contente de l'école c'était pas une
élève extraordinaire mais elle sentait
qu'elle était traitée à l'école pour
elle-même qu'on levait toute autre
considération sur ce qu'elle était sur
son origine et cetera et je je me
rappelle une très belle parole de du du
drabin Delphine orviller qui a dit à au
micro d'une d'une d'une radio publique
je crois que c'est en 2018 a dit la
promesse républicaine qui nous a été
faite c'est que chacun soit puisse se
développer lui-même à la première
personne du singulier et ça c'est c'est
ce genre de chose qu'il faut rappeler
aussi avec toutes les toutes les
dispositions républicaines et nous ne le
faisons pas assez bon il y a peut-être
une autoflagéation qui est une mode
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs mais il faut
arrêter il faut arrêter regard d'oè
là-dessus sur sur l'autorité enfin je
suis professeur donc je ne peux vraiment
que aller dans ce sens-là mais vraiment
je peux donner des exemples puisque tout
à l'heure tu nous as invité à donner des
exemples il nous arrive des fois de
faire face à des discussions avec des
étudiants qui disent on ne veut pas
entendre le mot pulsion parce que ça
heurte notre religion et on se trouve là
vraiment porteur on va dire de
connaissances d'un savoir et en plus
comme professeur on est bien entendu
psychanalyste ou psychologue donc on a
affaire à des expressions de la pulsion
et ces avatars comme disait Freud et des
fois comme je disais tout à l'heure je
tombe des nuU parce que vraiment c'est
des discours qui commencent à à revenir
mais de façon assez massive et à nous et
à nous menacer alors en ce qui me
concerne en ce qui me concerne donc moi
j'ai écrit beaucoup de comme ça sur la
question du dshérit dans l'Islam la
question du foulard la question des et
cetera et cetera je et je me pose
jusqu'à présent la question parce que
effectivement il y a un islam radical
fanatique qui est extrêmement dangereux
qui menace non seulement le vivre
ensemble mais qui nous menace nous aussi
qui menace aussi les pays arabes et
cetera et ce qui est vraiment ce qui me
chagrine c'est que cet islam fanatique
radical
abjecte
bah il met à l'arrière aussi tous les
autres aspects de la culture arabe et
aussi et tous les aspect de l'Islam
alors pour avoir traduit le Diwan de la
poésie arabe classique je vois que la
poésie c'est une chose que la
philosophie c'est une chose la mystique
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
on arrive devant quelque chose de de de
d'ultra même pas conservateur il faut
trouver vraiment un autre mot un
wahabisme qui nous tue nous aussi et
c'est celui-là qui s'impose et alors la
question trop long parce que le le temps
avance et on a beaucoup de question Mme
très important cette question je reviens
à la question adolescente avec la abaya
comment se fait-il que ces jeunes qui ne
connaissent pas l'arabe qui ne peuvent
pas lire le Coran qui oui mais enfin il
y a des influences extérieures oui oui
mais mais c'est quand même c'est des
sujets il faudrait complexifi et c'est
des sujets vraiment extrêmement
importants Michel gfel je disais
simplement répon aux observations
de de notre ami payon
sur la décision de Gabriel Atal de
d'interdire la BAA à l'école que
visiblement le ministre avait tenu
compte de l'opinion publique avant de
prendre sa décision puisqu'il y a eu des
sondages spécifiques sur cette voilà et
et que par la suite quand il a pris sa
décision cette décision a été euh
massivement appuyé par l'opinion
publique française y compris par exemple
chez les électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélanchon
qui sont censés être les les moins
hostiles à la place disons de l'islam
dans la société française je je je pense
que je pense que le débat sur la laïcité
est faussé en réalité pour une raison
très simple c'est que pas trop long ch
Michel parce qu'on a peu de temps
les guerres de religion les guerres de
religion ne sont pas des guerres sur un
dogme elles sont des guerres sur un mode
de vie ce qui a été fondamental par
exemple en France dans le vieux débat
entre l'Église catholique et les laïques
c'était pas une question de dogme
c'était la question du divorce et je
crois
que le vrai problème que nous avons
devant nous ce n'est pas un problème de
compatibilité de la religion islamique
avec le cadre républicain français c'est
une question de mode de vie y y a-t-il
dans la dans l'opinion française la
perception que leur mode de vie est en
danger y a-t-il dans d'autres milieux de
la société française la volonté le
projet d'imposer un autre mode de vie
voilà la véritable
[Musique]
question une question politique et
idéologique qui nous concerne tous
le mouvement de Mai
68 a été un mouvement
révolutionnaire les émeutes de juillet
2023 a été une
incandescence que certains considèrent
comme révolutionnaire et d'autres comme
violent est-ce que vous diriez parce que
vous avez rappelé que vous étiez de
famille communiste que le gauchisme
culturel
des années
68 à préparé la violence de
l'islamo-gauchisme
aujourd'hui bon les violences on les on
voit bien que le ton le ton même des
débats quand on aborde ces questions
c'est on cherche la violence on cherche
pas l'apaisement on cherche à désigner
les ennemis c'est un moment de
l'histoire on en parlera peut-être mieux
dans quelques décennie moi ce que je
crois pour ajouter une nouvelle idée à
notre débat mais qui était présente chez
jores qui présente chez Charles
Renouvier qui était présente chez
Ferdinand buon vous avez là le créateur
du Parti socialiste cfot vous avez là le
créateur du Parti radical socialiste
c'est la gauche finalement hein qui sont
aussi les artisans de cette belle loi
libérale de 1905 et souvent des
confessions vous le savez minoritaires
qui ont voulu s savez que Pascal Orri
rappelle que
l'antisémitisme trouve ses sources à
l'extrême droite et dans les frangches
de l'extrême gauche ça a toujours été le
le cas très tôt poudon et cetera mais là
on parle pas de on parle de jor et de
Buisson même si il y a certains textes
de Buisson qu'on pourrait relire de ce
point de vue-là mais la la question que
je veux soulever c'est que chez les
artisan de la laïcité française et bien
de la loi de 1905 la laïcité c'est un
principe liberté de conscience
séparation des Églises et de l'État
c'est aussi derrière une
philosophie et cette philosophie elle
s'accompagne d'une idée qui est que la
justice sociale l'égalité fait partie de
ce qui est nécessaire pour développer
cette instruction chez chacun et il ne
faut pas sous-estimer dans un pays où
les fractures sociales les fractures
territoriales sont aussi puissantes et
s'agrav que chez nous y compris dans
l'école je vais vous dire une chose
Monsieur met puisque vous êtes très
attentif à la laïcité il y a 600000
élèves dans les lycées professionnels le
dernier gouvernement qui a fait des
gesticulations extraordinaires avec
Monsieur Blanquer sur ces sujets à
supprimé l'histoire et la culture
générale à ces jeunes gens qui
croyez-moi viennent plus de banlieu que
du 7e arrondissement où nous sommes
est-ce que c'est une bonne chose non car
je crois comme ça a été dit qu'il faut
enseigner la République qu'il faut
instruire la laïcité mais là on s'est
dit ces gens-là c'est pas la peine on
retire des heures ça c'est très grave et
moi je suis pas contre qu'il ait pas de
malentendu entre nous cette histoire
d'abaya je suis pour qu'on parle aussi
de toutes les autres questions et qu'on
comprennent bien que ne faire que le
débat agonistique sur la laïcité permet
aussi de pas parler de plein de
problèmes l'accroissement des inégalités
dans notre système scolaire le
décrochage d'instruction de la France
par rapport à d'autres pays ça ce sont
des sujets massifs et parlons de la BAA
200 jeunes filles très bien mais parlons
du reste sinon la France va décrocher
elle est en train de le faire et c'est
dommage là-dessus Frédéric
salabarou je pense que je suis tout à
fait d'accord évidemment la question que
vous posez
c'est l'importance dans ce débat de
l'islamo-gauchisme effectivement c'est
quel chose est-ce qu' on peut le sourcer
par rapport à au gauchisme radical
Jean-Pierre legof dit qu'il était teinté
de violence et de nihilisme dè ses
sources oui mais d'abord la différence
entre 2004 et aujourd'hui c'est qu'en
2004 il y avait pas l'islamoguchisme et
donc c'était un débat qui n'était pas
troublé par cette
intrusion par la gauche enfin si tentait
que ça ça soit ça soit de la gauche
l'islamgauchisme dans le débat sur la
laïcité et
effectivement la question aujourd'hui
c'est la nature de de cet
islamogauchisme qui interroge par
rapport à la tradition de gauche et je
pense qu'il faut encore faire un pas
pour le comprendre de la laïcité jusqu'à
tout ce débat qualifier de terrorisme ou
pas par rapport au à ce qui s'est passé
en Israël derrière ça il y a une
question qui est au fond les valeurs de
la gauche et et Vincent payon qui a
écrit un un magnifique jores comprendra
il y a la gauche d'avant l'affaire de
rfus et la gauche d'après l'affaire de
rfus avant l'affaire de reffus il y a
une sorte de de radicalité qui fait que
on juge pas une personne en fonction de
ce qu'il est ou ce qu'il a subi mais en
fonction de sa classe sociale avec
l'affaire de reffus la gauche au fond
dit la question c'est pas de savoir où
est de reféfus c'est ce qu'il a fait
mais à partir du moment où il est
victime d'une injustice cette injustice
nous concerne tous et c'est le
basculement avec jores un peu gued aussi
de la gauche euh idéologique qu'on
pourrait qualifier aujourd'hui de de
plus plus plus plus gauchiste avec une
base antisémite très forte vers une
gauche humaniste et aujourd'hui tout le
problème de
l'islamogauchisme c'est de porter de
c'est cette c'est cette régression qui
consiste à tout
idéologiser jusqu'à perdre des choses
qui sont fondamentales ce qui nous
réunit à travers la laïcité présenter
cette valeur de liberté comme une valeur
au fond d'interdiction d'asservissement
et et d'aliénation et de à nouveau juger
les personnes non en fonction de ce
qu'ils ont vécu et des drames qui
peuvent avoir vécu mais en fonction du
positionnement dans une logique très
abstraite et très idéologique et ce
combat là au même titre qu'il faut avoir
un combat sur le terrain de la laïcité
il faut avoir un combat sur le terrain
de cet islamoguchisme et
singulièrement des des gens qui sont
inscrits à gauche c'est un un combat
fondamental nous à droite dans les
années 80 il a fallu assumer un combat
vis-àvis de l'extrême droite c'est
valable aujourd'hui pour la gauche
Frédric c'est la même logique de combat
pour des valeurs fondamentales quand
dériv des insoumis on entend qualifier
et assigné le CRIF le Conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
France à l'extrême droite et qu'on
décide que Fabien Roussel le leader
communiste c'est Dorio
est-ce que c'est la faillite quand même
d'un certain discours laïque mais peu
importe c'est c'est d'abord un terrain
de combat politique au fond ils sont en
train de retrouver là encore il faut
toujours faire de l'histoire en France
ils sont en train de retrouver le le
jacobinisme de 1794 c'est-à-dire il faut
des complots il faut des coupables il
faut des guillotines mais ce combatl il
faut l'assumer bien sûr que il faut
remettre les choses à leur place le CRIF
on peut contester ce qui ce qui peut
dire mais ça c'est un vrai débat mais il
est hors de question et c'est tout le
problème aujourd'hui des insoumis c'est
que la réalité n'est plus regarder en
fonction de ce qu'elle est mais en
fonction du d'une d'une classification
intellectuelle qui fait qu'on en oublie
la personne et en
arrivver à ne pas être capable de dire
acte de terrorisme acte de barbarie
c'est c'est montrer à quel point cette
dérive est devenue dangereuse et cette
façon et dans ces cas-là il faut la
combattre sur le terrain des principes
et c'est d'abord un enjeu pour la gauche
et la gauche joracienne mais c'est un
très vieux débat et que vous avez tout
juste un mot pour aller dans son sens
mais donner une clé de lecture sur cette
affaire Mélenchon et l'affaire avant
affaire drefus c'est qu'en fait vous
voyz bien ce qui est insupportable dans
l'attitude aujourd'hui de la France
insoumise et d'un certain nombre de gens
de la France insoumise car je crois
qu'ils sont pas tous sur cette position
c'est qu'il confondent la logique de
justice qui veut dire que là il y a un
individu et il y a des choses ce qu'on
ne peut pas accepter point de vue
politique moral et cetera et la logique
de domination et ils se disent c'est
comme la logique de classe il se disent
il y a des dominants des dominé et donc
c'est l'excuse par ça et c'est la même
chose qu'on avait au 19e et qu'on a
exactement dans ce moment depuis une
quinzaine de jours il y a des gens qui
continue de penser qu'il y a des
principes universels de justice qui
valent moins que cette logique là et et
cette gauche là ne s'en remettra pas
elle n'en se remettra pas parce que
notre pays n'acceptera pas et que la
gauche les électeurs de gauche majorit
ne l'accepteront pas mais c'est le même
débat vous avez raison de le dire c'est
ce moment où des principes moraux des
principes universels des principes
libéraux au sens des droits de l'homme
car le socialisme français est un
socialisme libéral au sens des droits de
l'homme et bien sont bafoués par des
logiques qui ne voi exclusivement elle
existe la logique de déomination mais
qui prend le pas sur ces principes vous
savez Vincent payon vous qui connaissez
bien l'histoire dans à l'échelle humaine
de Léon Bloom quand on lui a reproché de
ne pas avoir envoyé l'armée française
dans la guerre d'Espagne il a dit le
contexte ne le permettait pas parce que
mes amis étaient de moins en moins
socialiste et de plus en plus nationaux
vous voyez l'histoire Catherine Kinsler
je je voudrais dire que bon en 2004
effectivement ça n'apparaissait pas au
sous forme d'islamgauchisme mais
faudrait peut-être regarder je ne sais
pas si c'est toujours sur le site de euh
parlementaire les débats de la
commission stasie les auditions et
regardez l'évolution des personnes qui
avaient qui siégeaient dans cette
commission et qui n'étaient pas toutes à
droite quand elles étaient contre la loi
de 2004 bon je remonte en 89 puisque ça
c'est mon expérience personnelle et bien
en 89 il y en a qui se sont amusés à
éplucher les noms et sur les consonants
à dire ah Kinsler Finkel Crot Badinter
tiens tiens donc on avait quand même une
petite une petite musique qui se jouait
là et je pense aussi que rappeler que
nous avions nous nousous sommes fait
traiter carrément de FCHO hein de
faschist cet appel et il y avait
beaucoup de gens de gauche sur cette
position notamment je rappelle que la
fédération de l'éducation nationale
était tout à fait sur nous l'avons
trouvé en face de nous donc il faut faut
quand même rappeler ça alors Vincent
Peignon a tout à fait raison je crois de
rappeler la différence entre logique de
domination et logique de justice parce
que la lecture en terme de de domination
permets tout permet tout en terme
d'injustice k il nous reste 2 minutes un
mot si vous voulez bien auiable d' je
rejoins tout à fait votre point de vue
effectivement il y a de plus en plus de
précarisation il y a de plus en plus
vraiment de fissur au niveau du du tissu
social et moi j'apprends vraiment que
les étud enfin que les élèves de Bonlieu
où les élèves du du système
professionnel nai plus de culture
générale enfin moi je suis scandalisée
mais il y a quelques années j'avais
proposé parce que j'étais auditionné
par par aussi par le Parlement sur la
question de l'éducation moi je crois en
l'éducation j'ai dit qu'il fallait quand
même enseigner par exemple Avisen av
veros faire entrer des des des auteurs
comme Asia Jabbar amine malouf sur
identité meurtrière et cetera et ça ça
vraiment ça contribuerait à vraiment à
ce qu'on appelle le vivre ensemble aussi
entre les étudiants et les élèves merci
peut-être que vous serez entendu par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
Michel gurfinquiel un mot parce que on
arrive au terme l'horloge nous indique
que on est au terme de
l'émission un jour un ami américain m'a
dit ce qui est formidable avec la France
c'est que c'est l'éternel pays de
l'affaire drefus il voulait dire par là
que c'est un un pays où les querelles
sont sont mais où les mobilisations pour
sortir de ces querelles sont également
ce qu'elles sont et c'est une
singularité française qui finalement est
nous honore et nous permet d'espérer
merci d'avoir terminé sur ce mot
d'espérance je crois que René chard
disait résistance n'est qu'espérance
vous voyez donc les deux mots vont
ensemble il me reste à vous rappeler
mais très rapidement une bibliographie
alors Catherine Kinsler pensit la
laïcité c'est votre crédo c'est pas un
crédo ce sont des principes ben
justement c'est pas une religion civile
c'est le contraire et vous restez en
parler vous restez toujours sur je suis
sû oui ça c'est c'est je ne ris rien de
ce qui a été écrit làdedans très bien je
rappellerai que Jean-Pierre legof vient
de publier mes années folles c'est un
itinéraire fort intéressant il a été
quasiment un casseur en b68 et
aujourd'hui il considère que c'était de
la pure brutalité on en pensera ce qu'on
veut mais c'est le c'est intéressant
alors Frédéric
salabarou on a déjà parlé de votre Bloom
le magnifique pouvez dire un mot sur ce
que vous préparez ah c'est autre chose
c'est c'est c'est sur je prépare un
livre sur la bataille de la Berzina mais
qui est qui est l'occasion de de
réinterroger le parcours de Napoléon
notamment à l'ône des valeurs de de la
Révolution et puis de son vainqueur
Alexandre 1 qui qui est aussi à
découvrir alors
Abdel wed on a déjà parlé aussi de votre
livre face à la destruction psychanalyse
en temps de guerre un mot pour nos
téléspectateurs c'était mon travail
vraiment clinique avec les réfugiés
syriens et donc comment est-ce qu'on
travaille comment se fabrique des
séances avec des gens qui sont vraiment
des ENF qui ont tout perdu j'allais dire
alors Michel gfiniel euh vous avez un
livre en préparation sur l'hébraïsme
politique tout à fait tout à fait en
effet l'hébraïsme politique qui est ce
phénomène un peu oublié aujourd'hui mais
tout à fait fondamental par lequel
l'Europe qu'on appelle moderne des temps
modernes c'estàd l'Europe du 16e siècle
au 18e siècle à euh essayer de résoudre
ses problèmes internes en recourant non
seulement à la Bible hébraïque mais
aussi et c'est c'est tout tout à fait
intéressant à la tradition
juive à la tradition talmudique et
rabinique voilà c'est un phénomène qui
qui a touché les plus grands
intellectuels de cette époque merci
Michel gfel ce qui vous fait plaisir
Vincent Pillon voilà on a enfin traduit
en France le livre de Nelson sur la
République des Hébreux et le débat se
lance sur ce modèle moderne libéral du
17e 16e 17e siècle qui est le retour à
la Bible hébraïque à cette république
des Hébreux qu'on trouve même chez bossu
finalement chez Rousseau et qui a
inspiré sans doute le modèle moderne
politique mais qu'on qui qui avait
disparu dans le fond de la mémoire
collective c'est toujours intéressant
l'histoire se réécrit toujours vous
pouvez rappeler le titre de votre livre
alors le mien c'est tout chose c'est sur
le le le le judaïsme français Jérusalem
n'est pas perdu sur J s paru au bord de
l'eau au bord de l'eau mais la
République des Hébreux d'éic Nelson est
un très grand livre par un grand
professeur d'Harvard enfin disponible en
français merci alors il me reste à vous
remercier d'avoir
participé à cette émission il me reste à
remercier l'équipe de LCP qui a permis
la réalisation de cette émission et
avant de vous quitter je voudrais vous
laisser avec cette citation vous me
direz si vous reconnaissez son auteur
aujourd'hui nous ne devons pas nous
masquer quand on parle de laïcité on ne
parle pas vraiment de laïcité on parle
de gens qui au nom d'une religion
poursuivent un projet politique celui
d'un islam politique qui veut faire ses
sessions avec notre République vous avez
un nom et vous ben c'est l'actuel
président de la République Emmanuel
[Musique]
Macron